salut bienvenue dans cette vidéo de type
casse tête j'ai eu le plaisir de vous
dire que c'est le dernier casse tête
avant le plus gros casse tête que j'ai
fait sur cette chaîne à castets fait sur
mesure qui a coûté la somme modique de
15000 euros où on va bientôt le recevoir
ça va être dingue donc voici le dernier
cas c'est avant l'ultime et du coup
aussi le dernier partenariat qui permet
de financer ce projet car oui loïc cette
vidéo est sponsorisé par soeur sharks un
réseau privé virtuel que l'on pourrait
traduire par virtual private network ou
encore vpn si jamais tu savais pas d'où
ça venait mais alors pourquoi utiliser
leurs services les points intéressants
que j'ai pu relever sont entre autres
bien sûr un nombre d'appareils connectés
illimité et je crois que c'est de celle
des peines qui propose sa et une
politique de non journalisation pas dire
qu'ils lisent jamais le journal ça veut
dire qu'il stocke aucun journal
d'activité ou de connexion qui vous
concernent évidemment vous aurez tout ce
que vous attendrez d'un vpn avec des
belles performances comme vous pouvez le
voir à l'écran en ce moment même il ya
par exemple la possibilité d'autoriser
certains sites ou appris à contourner
votre vpn ça peut être pratique sur
sharks offre aussi une belle garantie de
confidentialité une sécurité sur les
réseaux wifi publics et une manières
d'accéder au contenu étranger qui vous
sont bloqués pour un internet plus
ouvert en utilisant mon kot fabien vous
aurez le droit à une réduction de 83%
sur votre abonnement et en + 3 mois
gratuits utilisation le code c'est
fabien tu veux retenir loïc bien oui
c'est ça à peu près mon prénom
ensuite bien exact donc seules correct
sachez également qu'il ya une garantie
de 30 jours satisfait ou remboursé si
vous voulez juste testé sur sharks sans
engagement ça c'est coupe de leur part
bref merci sur sharks
aujourd'hui on se fait un casse tête de
type boîte secrète à ouverture secrète
qui a l'air de changer de d'habitude
parce que évidemment quand je les ai
achetés j'ai vu qu'elle avait des
bâtonnets qui bouge ici et elle
s'appelle justement la sliding box
difficulté de ce casse tête selon loïc
tu connais bien le comité des
difficultés de castets 3 sur 6 à 4 sur 6
donc je devrais en venir à bout assez
rapidement en temps normal mais après ça
ça veut rien dire puisque suivant le
site mon bref on va pas remettre ce
débat on remet ce débat loïc on remet
pas devanand je crois fans c'est un très
beau casse tête il coûte un peu cher il
coûte 130 euros et là tu dis à castets
130 euros seulement 3 sur 6 je vous le
répète le
pris d'un casse tête n'est pas en
proportion nécessaire avec cette
difficulté on l'a vu sur le casse tête à
3000 euros qui était pas forcément très
dur c'est pas ça qui fait le prix du
casse tête donc mis un peu cher parce
que c'est du bois de palissandre qui a
un bois plutôt noble en existe plusieurs
essences je ne crois pas que ce soit la
plus recherchée celle ci il ya des très
beaux de jeu d'échecs par exemple qui
sont faits en palissandre et c'est
exactement la raison pour laquelle vous
vous regardez cette vidéo pour en savoir
plus sur le bois de palissandre
car si vous pouvez me parler de
l'essence de votre bois préféré en
commentaire je pense que vraiment on
fera bien avancer le débat
loïc j'aimerais quelques plans style et
de cette boîte en guise de générique
c'est possible ça est bien plein ce
qu'il est aujourd'hui c'est le sliding
boxe en exclusivité sur casse tête
manières pire cela est ici on a un joli
couvercle de type couvercle avec six
sortes de boucliers incrusté qui ont
l'air vraiment incrusté incrusté en
coller ça a pas l'air de bouger sur
cette tranche là on récupère les mêmes
choses je regarde juste s'il ya des
symboles particulier qui se répètent
tous ne se répète pas là sur le petit
bouclier
donc là on a clairement ces deux tiges
là qui bougent d'un côté et de l'autre
ça transferts ce nom
donc là on voit bien que la transperce
la donc ces deux là tu bouges ça ça
bouge aussi puisque je peux le pousser
sa force un peu plus en tout cas à celui
du tout ah oui si celui du tout aussi
d'accord
là-bas pareil ok lui aussi ou pas oui
celui ci aussi on peut les y force cela
ils forcent cette tranche la force ces
tranches la force plus que cette tranche
là là on a vraiment l'équivalent de ce
qu'on avait de l'autre côté là du coup
c'est l'autre côté d'eux des trucs qu'on
pousse et ça c'est juste du chevaillier
boîte ça ne bouge pas toujours ses six
mêmes bouclier tous amovible et en
coller est pareil ici on a fait le tour
alors maintenant la grande question
c'est est-ce que sur la boîte il ya un
an
2 qu'est ce qu'on doit faire avec ces
barrettes ou est-ce qu'il faut essayer
de trouver ça en tâtonnant comment elle
va s'ouvrir la boîte ça c'est pas bête
en fait l'idée c'est dire si je trouve
comme ans ouvre la boîte est ce qu elle
souffre comme ça ce qu'elle secoue lycée
ce qu'elles s'ouvrent
je ne sais pas latéralement je pense pas
mais là bas si l'un des deux preneurs là
c'est simple à comprendre et à des
lattes ce côté là on a tout se bloque là
donc ça veut dire qu'il va falloir
l'attiré comme ça ouais j'ai un tout
petit peu de jeu un tout petit
millimètre de jeu mais ça veut dire que
là ça passe ça passe sous les robes or
comme ça en bois il va falloir fit tirer
dans ce sens là j'ai exploré je suis
chercher s'il y avait un indice je
trouve rien de spécial on a huit bâton
qui traversent de part et d'autre la
boîte
donc ça fait pas mal de config sachant
que ils peuvent avoir trois positions on
va dire en fait c'est foule à droite au
centre et où fut la gauche donc ça fait
quand même pas mal de possibilités
différentes quand même ça fait ça en
match d'ailleurs un terme de code lui
possibilité qui en trois positions
différentes
c'est fait
dans 8 + 1 3 j'ai agi sur mon calcul
juin neuf positions différentes
en ayant deux tendons 3 donc ça va pas
être de puissance 3 du coup x 3 x 3 ah
voilà c'est ça ça fait trois puissances
8 3 x 3 x 3 x 3 petits calculs
tu peux me faire le calcul là donc il ya
6565 possibilité d'ouvrir ce casse tête
mais il doit forcément y avoir un indice
parce que là ils disent et 3 sur 6 ce
lundi
la difficulté 3,4 sur six états d'ici
côté c'est pas mal ce du buy list
vraiment tout seul tranquille ce duo ils
sont plus compliquées a poussé alors
est-ce que ce duo il servirait le genre
et ceux du bas il servirait peut-être
pas et sont là juste pour pour faire
style c'est une hypothèse du pacs est la
bonne mais parce que là dans ces cas-là
ça ferait trois fois 3 9 x 3 27 ça fera
environ 90 possibilité serait déjà
toutes plus raisonnable même si c'est
quand même nom de tester des trains des
possibilités ouais si j'appuie 13e ce
point coup ils tombent donc peut-être
que eux ils sont là que pour la déco et
pour mon fumée l'esprit en fait c'est
possible alors imaginons la gelée
pousser à fond dans l'huile super du rap
ou ses limites il veut pas d'ailleurs
être poussé complètement là bas qui se
fait pas plus malin en prenant un crayon
pour mieux les pousser je cherchais un
crayon fait de l'animation parce qu'on
va peut-être gardé le rush en entier
[Musique]
ah oui bah oui c'est moi telle micro
j'espère que tu leur as parlé quand même
ouais ok cool alors j'ai pris ça pour
m'aider à pousser les pitous ue je me
demandais loïc ça fait longtemps qu'on
n'a pas mis une vidéo sur la chaîne
secondaire alors qu'on a des gros
projets d'ailleurs pour cette chaîne toi
et moi vous le savez pas mais on a déjà
tourné des trucs avec le heat qui a à
peu près de dix ans avant qu'on se rend
compte
j'ai vu dans la dernière vidéo dans les
commentaires on a quelques uns qui
demander la vidéo en entier du casse
tête en ont coupé quand on vous met le
plan de face en entier sur la chaîne
secondaire fabien arrow post-it master
vous avez le lien dans la description
vous êtes à peu près 50 mille je crois
sur cette chaîne secondaire c'est
marrant de la montée aux 100000
d'ailleurs alors le trophée fabien route
tout serait parti d'une blague lors d'un
casse tête
là j'essaie de voir si on peut vraiment
tous les mettre dans les trois positions
ces duos parce qu'ils sont un peu durs
un peu à force est alors je sais qu'on
pense pas forcément sur la casse tête
mais on peut pousser un peu quand même
là on peut tous les pousser moi je pense
je pars sur cette théorie c'est ce duo
qui ont une influence sur le sur la
boîte
si lui par exemple je le mets à fond
vers moi le deuxième je le mets rentrez
rentrez rentrez j'ai pas testé les sens
quand même je vois à peu près 6 comme ça
s'il ya un truc qui se passe ah oui oui
et oui si j'arrivais peut-être à berlin
ça ferait pas tout bouge et wayne ainsi
vont commencer parce que je me demandais
si on pouvait commencer à le faire
glisser au fur et à mesure où est ce que
je veux dire alors si je pouvais
débloquer le baiia est qu'après ça
bloque peut-être théorie inexploitables
mais ça valait le coup d'essayer sache
trop c'est trop il est trop fluide le
bain on voit bien qui sera rien
[Musique]
lui par contre que je m'enfonce là j'ai
vraiment l'impression qu'il se passe un
truc est pas dès que je vois quand
est-ce que sa force
et quand est-ce que sa force - est
théoriquement si le bout de leur parle
des petits bouts de bois transversaux
d'ici force c'est peut-être qu'ils
rentrent dans quelque chose et qui
bloque quelque chose genre lui de
l'enfoncer très très dur là il a l'air
un peu plus libre quand il est là on va
dire à 0 par contre sortie à fond il est
trés enfoncé aussi c'est comme ça le
premier c'est le plus comme ça qu'il est
bien les sorties complètement de ce côté
lui lui il est très souple quand il est
comme ça
elle lui et lui des traits soupe quand
il est comme ça
du coup ma théorie était juste la bonne
mais je m'attendais pas du tout à
l'avoir fini la main
alors non ce qui se passait à temps
j'attends un peu avant d'ouvrir veulent
ouvrir en le faisant voir si tu es mené
ce qui se passe et que effectivement le
bas ne servait à rien et est donc j'ai
testé un peu la souplesse de la position
des quatre bio que jean foncé ou
j'enfonçais pas et du coup là ça s'ouvre
au stylet alors comment ça fonctionne
ah oui donc là ils sont tous alignés à
temps je comprends pas comment il
fonctionne ah oui non d'accord ok ok ok
ok ok ok donc ce qui se passe c'est que
ces quatre bois ils sont ils sont d
aligner deux c4 à ceux-là genre lui il
se trouve là lui il se trouve entre les
deux là lui entre ces deux là et lui
entre salles bord est ce qui fait que ça
c'est les passages et doivent être
ouverts ah oui c'est pour ça que je
pouvais pas avancer quand même au fur et
à mesure mais alors comment ma théorie
de la souplesse à la fumée des c'est
juste un hasard si possible ce que lacan
j'étais comme ça ça me paraissait plus
souple là quand j'étais comme ça c'est
ce qui me paraissait le plus souple et
de là toujours là c'est quand wayne on
lui il force mais ces hasards là qui
force
voilà c'est que quand ils ont travaillé
les pièces de bois
ah oui là sa force à mort pour le maître
comme ça alors que la taxe l'a6 où je
sais pas si j'ai pas rater quelque chose
qui était censé me donner les bonnes
indications pour sa part qu'on se trouve
l'intérieur de la boîte hyper stylé à on
peut même l'enlever carrément la boîte
et tous se mettent des petites choses
dedans genre voilà mon précieux alors en
prenant sortant salaire non oui cette
boîte est ce que je la fais gagner sur
un stade où est ce que je la garde
qu'est-ce qu'on fait le lit est belle
bon ben je la fais bien des gens non non
je la fais je la fais gagner sur un
style elle voit un peu d'argent quand
même lot presque 150 euros en tout bah
ouais c'est un beau cadeau la ferait
gagner sûrement instagram qui apparaît
ici avec lens à ces deux tiers loïc donc
sur - d'instagram qui apparaît ici et ce
sera cette photo là et dans la
description je vous mets le lien vers
mon instagram pour pour la gagner en
commentant sur poste du jour et puis et
puis je vous mets aussi le lien pour
ceux qui veulent l'acheter si jamais il
en reste il me semble que c'était une
édition limitée mais très très joli très
stylé très agréable étonné je trouve que
j'ai réussi à l'ouvrir avec de la
synchronicité il ya un petit peu de
hasard ma théorie à la marche et métier
c'est la théorie
les théories un peu chelou de il
s'appelle loïc loïc pratiquer pratiquer
patrick patrick irlande
tu vas aller en irlande c'est ça voilà
bah ça ça c'est une théorie ça marche
mais on sait pas pourquoi mais là ma
théorie de la souplesse du tasso
fonctionner mais je sais pas pourquoi
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo pensez à la lake et si vous aimez
les casse tête
on a un gros casse-tête qui arrive même
un gros genre le casse-tête qui valait
trois mille euros à côté c'était un cast
et de pas cher en fait être à côté de ce
qui arrive est un truc qui a été
fabriqué pour l'occasion qu'on a
commandée il ya quelques mois qu'il va
pas tarder donc
abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour pas le
rater activer la cloche parce que quand
il va sortir faut le voir tout de suite
su like et la vidéo je voulais dit là je
vous mets deux autres vidéos petit 1 le
casse-tête à 3000 euros non par les et
pourquoi pas le premier casse tête que
j'ai résolu sur la chaîne il ya quelques
années maintenant peut-être vous l'aviez
pas vu ça peut vous intéresser
moi je vous embrasse très fort à très
bientôt prenez soin soins point n'est
besoin de vous
olfa comme ça prenait fiom joue très
très bientôt